take care of the teams that you have now
I think that's so key I think that's
very very key I would love to expand I
would love we need more players there's
so many players out there that should be
on the WNBA roster that's not because of
just the way the team is set up but at
the same time for me I think we just
need to also take care of the teams that
are in market right now
[Music]
hello Asia what a beautiful walk-in
better than the first time huh
[Laughter]
you know this is uh this is what doing
uh TV is like how are you are you good
no I'm amazing happy to be in South
Carolina but I think we should just
rename like Columbia Asia Wilson town
because they love you here when I was on
the plane I was talking to you know my
neighbor I'd like to do that and he's
like what are you doing coming here I'm
like oh I have an interview he says with
who I'm like I'm gonna talk to Asia
Wilson you would have thought he was
about to stop this plane get in my
suitcase to come to this interview so
people really do love you here do you
feel that when you come to town I
definitely do I come back to South
Carolina it's just like a different vibe
a different feel like it's very loving
it's very caring and like sometimes it's
suffocating but I actually enjoy it
because I miss it I don't really get
that in Vegas so no I definitely feel it
here yeah and I think it has to be
really special too almost become like
synonymous with acidity like it's at the
point now I think when people think of
Columbia or University of South Carolina
they think of Asia Wilson and I think
that's a milestone in itself as well is
that something you'd always been
thinking about yeah it definitely is
like sometimes I see all the tweets I
see everybody they're like oh my gosh
Asia Wilson South Carolina like you just
got to put it together at all times and
it's a beautiful thing I mean I have
people in this state that have watched
me grow up since I was like an arm baby
so for them to be on that Journey with
me it's just really special yeah I love
that okay is it different coming back as
a champion
tell me the differences between that it
definitely is different coming back as a
champion um because I mean it's just a
different feel like I and everyone talks
about the Statue and it's funny because
I drove by there and I didn't even
recognize I was like my mom was like I
was like oh yeah it is here like I
because I'm away from it so many times
that I I'm not used to it but it is
different here of course I got a chance
to see coach Staley so she always brings
that Championship building back to me so
it's a great feeling how do you think
that you personally have changed being a
champion now oh
I think you spent all this time trying
to like just prove yourself trying to
make sure like everyone understands that
you know you put them on notice you got
to wake them up everyone's like in there
stay sleep like they sleep but for me I
think as a champion it's one thing that
you can't take away from me so I'm kind
of like all right I still got the chip
on my shoulder don't get me wrong I'm
still like greedy and I want more but
it's just a sense of like I put them on
notice like I did it that's this me you
can't take it away from me you can say
whatever you want because that was the
big thing that people really talked
about to me was just like oh but she
ain't got no rings like she ain't got a
ring I'm like well I gotta roll now yeah
so now what are you gonna say yeah it
kind of leaves you like all right so now
what you want to say and I think that's
the biggest thing that I've changed
about myself is just like my confidence
and my demeanor is just kind of like all
right I did it like I could check that
off my goal list like let's move on to
the next thing yeah okay and correct me
if I'm wrong it feels like even when you
didn't have the ring even when you were
hearing the voice of people talking
about you not having it you had a
calmness and Stillness because you knew
you would get it oh for sure yes I was
just waiting on my my journey I was just
waiting on my store worry for whatever
God had in stored for me everyone's like
how do you deal with the pressure I'm
like I don't feel the pressure really
because I know what I'm here to do I
know that I am guided uh and it
protected so I'm like I really can't
worry about that all I can do is put the
ball in the hoop the best way I can like
everything else is going to pan out but
it is also very good when you actually
do get to waste that trophy if you're
like yes all those days all those years
and so finally yeah now I gotta say I
remember in the the post game press
comments after y'all won and we're gonna
talk about that just so you know but
something I loved was when they were
talking about the Championships you were
like this isn't going to be the only
you're like I'm not gonna start naming
off numbers but I know another one is
coming you realize like that's a promise
you're making because you're gonna bring
another one to Vegas Yes and that's
that's just the bill that I have I think
the energy that the franchise that we
have the people around us it's a place
where it's like you know this is brewing
like it's just it's not just in the here
and now like it's great now but we're
trying to build like this was just the
the first and not the only and I'm not
that's why I was like I'm not
but it's hard it is hard winning a
championship on any level but when you
get to the pros it's very very hard so I
was like you know what I can feel it
like the our energy our locker room was
just different explain that to someone
who might not know what you mean when
you're saying winning is much harder
than you might think like winning is it
covers up a lot of things and I think
when you get down to the stretch that's
when things are exposed because everyone
you're under a microscope like
everyone's just like all right how can
we take away this from the Aces and what
can we do so winning covers up a lot of
that because it's like we're winning so
don't fix something that's not broken
but when you're getting down to the
nitty-gritty of things and you're
playing the same team for the fourth
time I'm like I know y'all players
better than y'all probably know y'all
players at this point it's hard because
you know like the back of your hand so
you really dial into those different
things like just that heart want to get
more that grit that just pushed through
and that's what it really comes down to
and it's hard to do that over the course
of like a week yeah every other day it's
hard to bring it every other day I mean
I don't want to get out of bed
yeah so that's what it's like what I'm
meaning by it's just really really hard
to win with yeah what's heavier the
expectations before you win a
championship or the expectations after
you win one
um
I would definitely say before especially
depending on the status that you're at
because like everyone's going to compare
you to someone everyone's going to
compare you to anything that's going
around you so those expectations are
just like well if they can do it you
need to be doing it and it's like well
maybe it's just not my time or maybe
it's just uh not a feel for it and I
think Meeting those expectations are 10
times harder because once you got it you
got it I remember Bill lampier uh my
coach a couple years ago when I was even
drafted he was just like once you win a
championship it's like you got it you
got that secret and you can't really
tell anyone because it's like you're
just in it you live it you know you've
been in those moments you've been in
those big lights and it's like that's
the secret but getting there oh my God
it's like looking over and you're trying
to find look over a mountain in the
valley you're just like I can't get
there yeah but something about it like
once you get it you just get a feel for
it okay so a lot of times no people say
winning that Championship is the best
day of their life so I'm gonna ask you
what are your three best days of your
life if that is one of them three best
days of my life definitely winning that
WNBA Championship was like Top Notch
um
my first game at South Carolina my
freshman year is an exhibition game at
noon it was the first game I know
exactly it was the first game my
grandmother ever see me play like ever
like she would always watch me and
sometimes she wouldn't watch me because
she thought the defender was trying to
beat me I was like it's a part of the
game Grandma but that was her first game
that she ever came to and her only game
that she came to and uh that was
probably top-notch top tier ever and the
third one
I don't know I'm trying to think oh the
third one probably has to be SEC
Championship my senior year okay we
played against Mississippi State and we
were The Underdogs but we were the
number one seed it was very confusing
yeah that doesn't make sense but I was
like and that's what made it that much
more sweeter because everyone wanted us
to lose so bad and that was my fourth
one and I was just like I'm going out
with a bang like this was cute
Mississippi State but nice try yeah so
those three moments right now at the top
of my head have to be like the biggest
moments of my career I mean they'll just
be good effects but on that Championship
Championship day I have to ask most
importantly was that the most drunk
you've ever been in your life
yeah because I love the press conference
and the parade I think that was the
fastest I've ever became drunk because
people don't realize we're coming fresh
off the court like I don't have anything
in my system but some applesauce like
and you're handing me this beer and then
we have champagne and I'm like oh my
gosh by the time I look I'm like seven
bottles are just around me and I'm just
like all right then like come on guys we
gotta do press conference I'm like oh
all right let's go for it like I'm
didn't have a shirt I didn't know where
anything was so yeah that was the
quickest and probably the most I've been
but I mean the memes and the gifts that
came out of it it was so worth it it was
absolutely the best all of your facial
expressions you're like looking at just
be like what is going on do you even
remember most of it or do you just know
it because you've watched it back I know
it because I watched it back and I
remember uh the biggest thing that I
remember is just KP coming in with the
Boombox like yeah just lit and anyone
that knows Kelsey Plum she is like Stern
and like no I'm gonna eat my vegetables
every day I'm drinking water and I'm not
touching anything and to see her like
that I was like oh my gosh my girl
loosened up yeah so it was just a big
moment for me like I was a proud big a
little sister there I was like oh look
at her she's so drunk yeah but
that was the best moment probably okay
tell me the best story from either the
parade or Championship night that no one
has heard
um I don't even know if I can tell this
but we'll see
you can yeah give your permission yeah
ask for forgiveness not permission you
know
um there has to be we were on the bus
headed to the airport and Becky comes
back with like all this cash and she
just starts throwing it on the bus and
so we're like this is probably the first
time we've ever boxed out because they
do not box out we try but we didn't we
have a lot of people like everywhere I
was like oh [ __ ] we were grabbing money
and I turned a look and Jackie young
probably the quietest person in the WNBA
has she's like been in these dollar
bills like hundred dollar bills like hey
and I was just like oh my God we really
want a championship like that was the
moment where I'm like oh Jackie's like
lit and I don't think anybody really
knows that but we were stumping on the
bus people drawing on the like on our
bus get the hundreds so yeah that was a
big one it was a big money I was
thinking
um
dollar bills I said come on honey who
won a hundred dollar bill Benjamin yeah
come on I was getting every Benji on
that bus I promise you okay how much did
you walk away with
I love that and you know I think winning
a championship probably brings that out
of people shout out to Jackie because he
was able to to loosen up a little bit
yeah okay so speaking of Buckingham in
what makes Becky Hammond good besides
throwing out the hundreds
um the way she sees the game and I think
she's already had it in there and then
being under pop was just cherry on top
like the way she sees the game the way
that she analyzes it for us to
understand and to bring our strengths
out is something that I've never ever
seen before like not even taken away
from my other coaches but she's like I
always say Becky had better knees she
would be practicing with us because she
sees the game she's that competitive and
it makes you want to buy in to like play
with her and play for her and went for
her so I think that was the biggest
thing for us and it was just a breath of
fresh air for us like and it was also
cool because no one really knew us we
were a new system everybody was like
we're trying to figure us out and so it
was like definitely big time for us what
was your relationship with Becky Hammond
to start the season and then what was
your relationship with her ending this
season how did that progress oh man it
was pretty much consistent honestly like
when I first met Becky it was straight
out they gave she was like I want to get
to know you I want to understand who you
are and I want to understand where you
want to go and I love people like that
she keeps it black and white No Gray
areas so she knew exactly what she was
going to get out of me and I knew the
same for her and as the season went on
our talks just got deeper and more
intuitive and just like this is who we
are like I'm like this is what we could
do this is what we're capable of and
Becky just took it in she was like all
right I'm gonna give you the blueprint
of foundation go build it and that's
what we did so I think it just grew in
that area just like our conversations
okay well speaking of blueprint your
resume is obviously stacked but what is
an Accolade that you want that you have
not gotten yet
hmm
[Applause]
I don't feel like I've got the most yeah
and I was about to say like one of those
like the Nickelodeon Kids Choice Award
blimps yeah I do not have one of those
and I really want one of those
um maybe even to get slime depending on
what my hair is like I don't do that
slime stuff but I think that's one that
I really want I wanted defensive player
of the year but I already got it so yeah
one of those kids dressing words orange
books I think that'll be pretty dope and
now you're just trying to conquer the
other level if you like what else can I
do nice I want to go get slime and get a
blimp and like have some fun okay no
fair okay I know that this is subjective
but for you who is the goats on the WNBA
hmm
I'm trying to think
who is the goat for us
I don't know that's a hard question
because I know you said like one of your
favorites you said Lisa Leslie yeah but
is that your goat
yeah like Lisa Leslie's a goat in my
eyes because she just
her Swagger and who she is and just the
grit that she shows it's just been
incredible and I didn't even get a
chance to watch her play like live in in
into it but when I go back and I look
I'm just like she was really Unstoppable
and she made everyone around her better
in my eyes that's a goat to me but we
have plenty of great players and I mean
like the list goes on about our league
because we're phenomenal women and very
elite of what we do but for me Lisa
Leslie is like up there yeah because you
know in that press conference Chelsea
Gray was saying I feel like we can start
talking about Asia Wilson being on that
path and trajectory to be yeah the
greatest women's basketball player of
all time I'm sure that's a lot to hear
that but with that Foundation being laid
what are the things that you think you
have to do to solidify yourself in that
conversation winning winning and just
winning I think that's the biggest thing
is just it doesn't matter how you do it
winning and like I said it covers up a
lot of things people just be like okay
what you want like she's a winner at the
end of the day I want to be a winner and
not necessarily just on the court but
off the court as well like I'm very
particular in that area but I think when
it comes winning everything else Falls
in line and when it comes to go as well
it's just
making people better around you like I
think that's my biggest thing is okay
cool it's great having fun playing
basketball but I want to get my
teammates involved I want to be
productive without the basketball and
those little things there I think those
are signs of a goat and just when you do
that and you do the right things and you
play the game the right way everything
else kind of Falls in line you were
obviously always playing basketball but
were you playing knowing that your
career absolutely okay yeah absolutely
not we were in the gym where I did not
have a clue what I wanted to do with my
life I love volleyball volleyball is my
first love I didn't want to give it up I
cried when my daddy said I had to give
it up and just looking back on it I
didn't want to sweat I didn't want to do
anything because ew so playing
basketball I never would have thought it
would have opened doors and would have
had the career that I've had thus far
um because it just wasn't on my radar I
just wanted to live life I wanted to be
normal do little things kind of go to
prom go to movies with my friends
but then I was like okay this basketball
thing's kind of cool yeah I'm gonna do
it for a living and then that's when it
just kind of took off so my I had no
idea yeah so becoming by Michelle Obama
is like one of my favorite books and
something that she talks about in it is
people who decide to make that swerve
and how like making that swerve really
can determine what your life looks like
it shows you what your passions are and
if you loved volleyball but you decided
to make that swerve to basketball yes
that just like one decision that you
made literally changed your entire life
yes and like the gravity of knowing that
like everything that you do is just
based on like little choices that you
decide to make and it sounds like what
you said was a lot of that choice was
your dad yeah so your dad is like such a
big reason why like this is all this
moment yeah he's a big part of me I mean
I wouldn't be Asia Wilson the basketball
player if it wasn't for him and I gotta
credit him and my mom because they kept
me so balanced like my mom was like no
let her go to prom and my dad was like
well she needs to be in the gym she's
like no she needs to enjoy these moments
like they allow me to still be a normal
teenage girl but yet never lose sight of
just kind of like my dreams and they let
they let me live them like when they
came to my college decision they're like
we're not going there four years you are
you make the decision what do you feel
like yeah and my dad just plays a huge
part in that for me and he's probably
put his career aside and his job aside
to even play go over with me to China
like those little things there stick out
the most to me and I'm a family girl
through and through like those are my
road dogs like I don't go do like I
really without my parents for sure and I
have no shame in that because they've
done so much like they sacrificed so
much for me and if I can make their life
easy I'm all for it isn't it interesting
like as you get older you realize hey
everything your parents do for you would
be how much you're like your parents oh
God yes it's super scary like I kissed
myself oh my God it's not like my mom
yeah that's something my dad would say
uh but the one thing they don't tell you
is how you got to parent your parents
yeah oh my God I'm like this is what I
had to go through oh no I can't take it
but no I love him I love like watching
them just watch watch me in a sense
because they're just so joyful and it
just helps me play like they're my why
like yeah my dad probably has 175
pictures of a statue
and he's like no come on let me take a
picture I'm like Dad literally I live
with you like you FaceTime me every day
that's okay so that's so big to me it's
just those little things is just so key
to me what I always think about and I
know that you'll get what I'm saying so
you have two dogs
I think about how much I love my dogs
and then I'm like I know it's times a
million
and I can't fathom that because my dog
I'm like nobody loves anything on this
side I promise you know where I love my
dogs yeah but it's like no your parents
love you more than that and that is very
wild to me that's like my barometer
for all things so it's just shout out to
the parents shout out to my mom and dad
shout out to her mom and dad all my
things I love that
um I was watching an interview that you
did and in it you said that you didn't
know who you were until you were 24 25.
what did you find out at that time
um I'm not perfect and I can't please
everybody and the bubble really as crazy
as the bubble was it really allowed me
to do that because I was by myself I
couldn't do anything but play basketball
and think and when I gave you that time
just to really dial into who I wanted to
be and and my light in and my guidance
um it was huge for me and I realized
that I could have bad days I realized
that I don't have to do everything and
I'm not gonna be perfect like the way
one person may see Asia Wilson is not
gonna be the same as the next and I
think I got so caught up into trying to
just please everybody and making sure
that I talk right I sound right I looked
right and it's like at the end of the
day I was losing myself like I was just
I felt terrible I hated everything that
I did it just wasn't life was not fun
for for me and once I got into the
bubble and kind of liked the stripped
for me and I had to just kind of be
there it allowed me to realize that like
a lot of this stuff that I prioritized
was not it and I was just like I'm I'm
giving a lot more and receiving nothing
like I was watering and no one was
watering me and I hated that feeling so
I found different ways and and got into
with myself and understood who I was and
I was like wow like this is me take it
or leave it yeah like it's gonna be some
days where I I can't sign that autograph
but I promise you I'm not like it's okay
and I have to accept that and I got so
angry with myself because I didn't want
people to be like oh she's this she's
dead and I'm like I can't control that
no matter what you do people are gonna
always have something to say and that's
what I had to really gain and it's like
I can't control that but I'm gonna be me
if I'm me I'm good like you get what you
get like I promise you this is who I am
and I'm not changing like I just really
found myself in that way yeah and the
peace is yes yes I'm like oh I'm good
yeah nothing worries like nothing
bothers AJ at this point yeah can you
give me an example you were saying I
felt like I had to talk a certain way
act a certain way what do you mean by
that
um I mean my rookie year I got in and
they're like well we want you to be the
face of this franchise and I'm like well
I'm a rookie I don't know what I'm doing
here just got here but thanks and I just
felt like I had to be this
person for the media or this person that
people wanted to go buy that Jersey for
and to go look at the game and fill in
the seats and it wasn't me and I'm like
yes I'm gonna dance my tail off and then
lay up line because I can like that's me
that's what I do I like that's how I
express myself and I just found myself
just really just digging in that hole of
just yeah saying everything that people
wanted to hear and not necessarily what
they needed to hear and that just really
struck my core because I would go home
and I'm like I didn't mean any of that
like they need to know how I feel and
what things that I'm going through
because I felt like people needed to
hear that and people related to it and
that's how you that's when you get the
jerseys and that's when people come see
you play so that was just big to me it's
like not just being politically correct
all the time being me and being real
yeah and I think that's what has allowed
so many fans to like actually connect
with you because now that you're being
yourself they feel like they are
actually connecting with you yes right
you're not like this thing that is
manufactured everybody wants to see yeah
I'm sure you feel like things have been
unlocked now that you can just be yes
who you are yes it really has and I mean
if I saw it more this year than ever
like I always lean on my teammates so
much and I and they give me so much
energy and just so much hope and passion
for the game and I just felt it a lot
this year yeah you've been really open
about depression and anxiety and how it
has affected you and I know that it
looks different for everybody so what do
depression and anxiety look like for you
who me I mean there'll be days where
Asia does to talk she wouldn't eat
um I just really felt like just a loser
like a loser like I was just like I
don't I had no energy to just give I had
no energy to smile and I just kind of my
parents kind of saw it and they're like
well this isn't us this isn't the child
that we raised like she's way too
blessed to be looking like this and I
just felt like I was just in a hole and
it just kept getting deeper and deeper
and deeper and as I saw that little
light up top and I'm like I'm gonna get
to it one way or another and I think
it's understanding that every single day
is a challenge and it's a battle but
it's just you gotta find a way to grind
it out you gotta understand but at the
same time understand that it's okay yeah
you can have those bad days you can go
through days where you're like I really
don't want to do anything today and
that's what I care I just felt like I
was just trying to reach for something
it just kept getting further and further
and further but once I got who I was
that life started to get a lot bigger
because I'm just like all right I'm
making my way up to the top because I am
who I am but those days it was terrible
like my I would have some pretty bad
anxiety attacks and I just felt like I
needed to be perfect I felt like I
needed to be
so not everybody wanted and I lost sight
of who Asia Wilson really is and and
that right there I was like I would
never go back to that place ever again
no for sure how did you start to be able
to cope with it how did you get better
with it and are you still dealing with
it right now I'm still dealing with it
right now it just comes in different
shapes and forms honestly
um but I would just honestly I started
digging into my Bible a little bit more
I started talking to my parents and
people my friends I started surrounding
myself with people that I knew wanted my
best intentions and it wasn't just for
the glitz and glamor of whatever this
life that we live as celebrities or
whatever you want to call it it was just
true people and my parents were really
ask me like how are you and I wouldn't
be like I'm good I would literally be
like I'm feeling terrible I hated
hearing the bubble like saying those
things were really helpful to me because
I was honest with myself yeah and I
think that's the big thing is just being
honest with yourself and then you start
unraveling who you are as a person but
if you're not honest with yourself you
can't expect people to really help you
and to gain and to think that you're
going to move forward because you're
honest with yourself what was the
hardest part of being honest with
yourself
that is honesty's ugly it's real it's
it's truthful
um and it's not just like oh man I had a
really bad game I should have made more
shots like no why did you have that back
here you didn't you I didn't go to the
gym when I wanted to I did I should have
been there and I think it's just that
ugly truth that you have to face with
yourself sometimes that's hard but you
gotta face it and you gotta live it in
order to move forward yeah and so for me
when I had to tell those other truths
and I'm just like I really don't feel
like doing this and I don't want to
smile
people gonna think I'm being a babe but
no like it was that was hard for me
because everyone expected me to be the
happy-go-lucky smile in Asia and I
didn't have it and that was hard for me
to battle but once I got past that I was
like hey it is what it is at this point
take it or leave it no for sure you know
it is always really striking to me when
I have these conversations because we
talked a lot about you know Mental
Health on the show we talk a lot about
therapy on the show we talk about you
know being authentically you want makes
you feel good but
there's always you know this thing when
we're talking to women about it so much
of it is we're feeling like we have to
be caring all the time or nice all the
time or smiling all the time and it's
like those labels that are putting the
pressure on us and then that allows like
that anxiety and these like these mental
health issues to manifest in a different
way than they manifest in men does that
make sense for sure and especially the
black woman yeah oh my God you have to
look a certain way you kind of wear your
hair a certain way because that it gives
it gets you a job yeah it gets you a job
and those little things are just so
particular to me and that's why when I
started advocating for this I wanted to
let everybody know that it's you have to
be you sure at the end of the day you
have to be you and it's hard because
it's some people that get jobs that are
not even on that tier that they're
supposed to be on but they get it
because hey that's what they want you
feel like you have to wear this mask and
I remember I was writing a player
Tribune story and I was just like we
have to sometimes take that mask off
every single day I felt like I was just
taking my mask I was like all right well
that was a good day of just smiling yeah
but here I am going back in my bed not
not talking to anyone and I had to break
through that and it's hard like it's
really hard even if our league is
predominantly black women it is still 10
times hard because you have to fight I
remember my mom would always tell me you
have to work 10 times as hard as the
next person just to get your foot in the
door and I didn't really understand that
until I got to the professional level
and it's like no matter how hard you
work it's gonna be somebody that's
always going to try to discredit you yes
no matter what it is I'm like uh it's
like you do all these things they're
like oh but she tied her shoes wrong and
it's like damn oh yeah like how are you
even if someone think about that no like
it's real like that's what we live no I
say this all the time any time I see a
black woman in a position I know she is
the absolute best at it yes because
everything was put in place
I am over confident in their ability to
get that job done yeah like and it's
crazy that it has to be that way and
that we have to feel that way but what
relationship do you see between black
women and vulnerability
oh no I think that is where it becomes
kind of Taboo in the black community of
that because we're always taught you got
to be strong hey don't let nobody see
you crack because we have to be there we
have to present ourselves in this way
because they're looking for a reason to
be like no sorry yeah and I think being
vulnerable is it plays a huge key in
that because you know you get so used to
putting up all these walls in these
Gates and it's hard to break through
it's hard to let those gates open a
little bit because of the trauma of what
you've gone through of the rejection of
the nose of the sorry we can't do this
other declines like it's hard to be
vulnerable in that situation but I think
the beauty of it on the other side is
when you understand that there's other
people that are like no I go through the
same thing that you're not alone and
that was me when I was vulnerable with
my mental health with my learning
disability I was very very suspect about
it but once I put it out and I felt like
people were just like you know what I
have a kid that goes through the same
thing or I go do the same thing oh my
God I relate to that that then made me
like all right I'm good and I think it
also gave people an opportunity to see
that I'm human yeah they see me in
uniform and they're like oh no she's
living the best life she's doing what
she's doing but they forget that I'm a
human that I have feelings that I will
clap back on Twitter because that's me
if I have my phone in my hand that's me
and I think that was the part that I
could connect with my fans even more
because I kind of pulled those heart
strings for them and let them know like
I'll go through it too trust me and it's
hard but I think that's kind of how it
is you have to find that it's a thin
line that black women have to kind of
push through to understand that like
sometimes you got to open that gate a
little bit yeah what Freedom has this
given you oh a lot of freedom oh my God
it's different things like I wouldn't be
where I am today or would probably
wouldn't have won a championship if I
didn't have that freedom of just lifting
that weight off my shoulder of just
being who I am through and through
because that was like another Defender
because I'm just like I'm battling with
all these things and now I'm going into
the game my mental somewhere else I'm
not in the game I'm not there for my
teammates and it just took a lot away
from me so it's a lot of Freedom now I
don't think about it I'll just go out
there and play now no I think that's
that's so insightful you're saying that
dealing with this was like another
Defender yeah so it's like you're kind
of fighting this too from war like with
you know the players on the court but
also what's happening here and trying to
figure that out and you feel like things
were unlocked when you were able to
really just be present okay what's that
message that you would maybe give to
other black women other athletes about
you know making sure that you take care
of both fronts
I think that's the the biggest thing and
I and we hear it all the time is it's
okay to not be okay I think that's the
biggest thing is understanding that
every like I said every day is going to
be a challenge and that's okay like you
are fully equipped you are guided enough
to get you through the day and just
tackle it day by day I think we get so
caught up in what's going on next what's
going on tomorrow you got to stay in the
moment and realize that we don't get any
of these moments back yeah and it's hard
it's hard to do that because oh we all
have stuff going on we all are bringing
something to the table or something and
it's like you just gotta tackle it day
by day and being true to yourself and
knowing that
you don't have to know it all right now
like kind of just I hate saying go with
the flow because it seems like I'm like
really just go with the flow and let it
all pan out because what's for you is
going to be for you regardless no I love
that I'm so happy that you were able to
be open and you feel like it was
meaningful to you I know it's meaningful
to so many people so I absolutely love
hearing that
um when we talk about you on the court
right you've been in the league four
years now
professionally and basketball wise what
year taught you the most about yourself
uh last year last year losing to Phoenix
um in game five at home
struck me in a way that I thought I
thought the bubble was bad because we
got sweat and getting sweet is not the
best feeling ever I can imagine one star
wouldn't suggest anything but no like
that losing that was like heartbreaking
like I just felt like I did not do
enough
so that off season I worked my butt off
to make sure that I could give more than
enough yeah and I think I got so caught
up in like all right well I'm in my spot
I'm doing what I need to do and I lost
sight of trickling over to my teammates
being more for them and that did not sit
right with me at all because that's not
me that's not me at all that should be
no one so that there was a moment in a
year that I learned the most about
myself and how I could push myself how
hard can I really go and I and it kind
of paid off this year for sure because I
could just push myself to a limit like I
put myself in situations where it was
really hard it's like when those
magicians go in them tanks and they
gotta find the key yeah it was one of
those things like I'm really testing
myself so I know my limit and when I
feel like I'm getting to that limit I
know I can bust through yeah and that
was just a big moment for me
what is the feeling of Asia Wilson oh
there's no ceiling honestly I'm I'm
trying to shatter every glass ceiling
there is I feel like there's no ceiling
for me I'm gonna go and go until uh I
feel like I'm good I'm I'm done enough
and I'm not even close to that uh people
are like oh you think you're in your
prom I'm like I think I'm just knocking
on the door I don't even think I'm there
yet I still think I have so much more to
give to this game and to my community
and everything else in between so if
you're not in your Prime right now I
know right it's crazy how much scarriers
are gonna get all right listen I put
that in God's hands because I gotta
start getting it's getting real now it's
fun and now I feel like I'm in the lead
because I got me when I'm like all right
now it was rookie year now I'm going in
it's year two now for me yeah I love
that I'm sure some of us in this like
dang and that wasn't her crime yeah so
we what we gonna do coming up how are
you better next season you specifically
oh how am I better
um
I'm more vocal I'm going to be a more
vocal leader I feel like my team is
probably like she talks enough
um but no I think I think I'm more vocal
because I see a lot of things and I
don't say anything because I feel like
Hey we're all Pros like we have our own
thing that we see I'm not gonna get in
the way but I think next year I'm gonna
be more president vocal in that
situation for my teammates in ways that
they know that they can count on me in
any situation not just in my position
but across the board okay I love that
speaking of being vocal one of my
favorite bites was when you were doing
like uh you were on the court doing an
interview with Holly and Kelsey goes
well you know Asia cussed me out before
the game tell me that story yes when it
comes to KP I let her know every single
it's one of those things that I've
learned about being a leader you have to
talk to everybody different I can't talk
to Jackie the way I talk to KP I can't
talk to KP the way I talk to d'erica and
that right there when kp's Mission shots
I'm like you need to make shots
I don't I'm not understanding why you're
not making shots KP never leaves the gym
she she was 200 shots a day why are you
missing shots and I kind of got into her
head her head a little bit I started
saying you need to be BBB get your BBB
together because we need you like we
needed that for her and I didn't want
her to seep into the mind game of my
mission shines oh my God I'm like make
your shots and move on that's why I'm
not asking is it a 360 winmail dunk I'm
not asking you to go between the legs
across somebody up I'm just asking you
to do your job and that's to make shots
thank you I love it so yeah I kind of
let her have in that one yeah have you
always been able to have that sort of
I don't know if tough love is the right
word but that very like blunt yes
communication with your teammates and
has it always been received well for
sure it's my mom that's my mom's side
100 uh Eva will tell you all quickly and
with a smile like maybe with a smile
maybe not and keep it moving and that's
me like I feel like I've developed Bond
bonds and relationships with my
teammates to where they understand that
it's tough love like it's don't take it
personal we're all here to do something
but they know at any given day they can
call me at any time and I'll love to
have a conversation with them we will
laugh we'll cry or do anything in
between but when it comes to doing your
job and what I need out of you and what
you need out of me and holding each
other accountable I'm all for it I feel
like it's always been me
um I just gotta find different ways to
do it but I really love forming
relationships with my teammates in ways
that I know I can talk to them tell me
like one thing or one moment that you
can point to that really bonded this
team oh man our tortilla slap challenge
uh KP bought these uh tortilla things to
practice no I know it yeah and I think
it really allowed us to get out a lot of
anger and KP was really hit me like I
lost lashes the way she hit me I was
like girl so the tortilla slap is you
take tortillas and you literally slap
you got water in your mouth yeah so you
can't laugh you can't spit the water and
we're all in a circle and you don't know
who and when someone's laughing like
it's not everyone gets a turn so you're
just slapping so we're looking and next
thing you know just slapped you and I
think that moment really brought us
together because you could tell we just
had a lot of fun with it we're just a
fun team as a whole yeah but some people
got their stuff out like I was like okay
KP I got you like you got me one yeah I
was like okay like cool thank you but it
allowed us to kind of like beat us be
the kids that we are and I think that
brought us together and I was early in
the season so I already knew then I was
like oh yeah we're in good shape so
there was anger in their Studio slaps
but there was lovely at the end of the
day we loved each other but some people
had some beef like okay I'll put a
little in it oh my gosh I love that okay
so uh kind of last section for you I
think that obviously we talked about the
WNBA a lot yes but sometimes I don't
think that we're actually talking to
WNBA players
um about what they would like to see
from the WNBA so I'll see some topics
going on right now one is WNBA having
more teams yeah you feel like the WNBA
should have more teams
um yes I do and but at the same time
take care of the teams that you have now
I think that's so key I think that's
very very key I would love to expand I
would love we need more players there's
so many players out there that should be
on the WNBA roster that's not because of
just the way the team is set up but at
the same time for me I think we just
need to also take care of the teams that
are in market right now the 12 that we
have it should be I love being at Vegas
because I think it sets the standard of
what a professional team should look
like in a WNBA league and I mean you got
Seattle you have all these great cities
that have the perfect amount of space
and fan base to take care of where they
are but I just think Riley just needs to
push a lot more and understand that
treat everybody like not the same of
course because Vegas is better I don't
need nobody to think today on the same
level as us but no like take care of
your your babies that you have now
before you go out make it small babies
right right take care of your kids now
make sure everyone's in the right space
where they need to and then you can
start talking about that but I would
love some extra teams I love I don't
know about a travel situation but what
you know we'll make our way there yeah
we'll get there someday so you're like
definitely more teams but we can't even
Broach that conversation until like our
house yeah is clean yes what are some of
the things in the house that you want to
be clean oh man how much time do we have
um no I think it's just the biggest
thing is
just treating us like professionals like
what we do we We Are Who We Are we work
so hard to get to this level it
shouldn't be a step back it shouldn't be
a step back from Collegiate level at all
it should be a step forward to where we
want young girls in college to be like
yes I want to go get drafted yes I want
to play for them yes I want to be in the
W and it just first with their franchise
and the owners whether it's the owners
whether the coaches whether it's the
players understanding taking the
situation that you have and making the
best of it but making it best for you
and then plant that seed for the Next
Generation for that rookie that wants to
come in take the money your wing and
show them the ropes like I feel like
that is what we need in our league is
just not just bitter and being like all
right well they got that no like focus
on your own group get your get your
squat together and then build from there
yeah and I think so much of it too is
like value like making people feel
valuable like their talent is valuable
that what they are bringing to you know
the sports space is valuable and I think
a lot of it um starts with that as well
well
um also some talk about you know celebs
that want to buy teams and your perfect
world tell me four celebrities that you
want to become a part of WNBA Beyonce oh
Usher
Serena Williams
and
it's giving like
I need an actor I'm looking at like a I
love me some Ryan Reynolds
okay come on Ryan come on right give me
your pitch to Beyonce that's what I
Beyonce girl honey listen
I don't care
get you a team girl I don't know if I'll
be playing for it cause I like Vegas but
girl it'll be great to come to your
house you can set it up at your house
girl come on be outside
the gym at the house like girl let us
come to the house we ain't gonna do
nothing you won't even know I'm there
but yes I feel like you should really
get a team Beyonce because like
it goes hand in hand at this point
Beyonce WBA I think it's perfect so
y'all say girl baby
come on holla at me yeah I don't think
that would be a better pick than that to
be honest so that doesn't convince
Beyonce I don't know uh I don't know
what else well I love that Beyonce WNBA
there's some there's energy I mean I
think I think it's perfect to me good
list I love it I love it
um so these episodes are sponsored by
Ally they are huge Advocates of women's
sports and pushing the game forward so
what do you want to see from women's
sports in the next 10 years
I want to see it more I just want to see
it more I think we're there I think
we're pushing the envelope but they were
almost there we're cracking we're
cracking that glass ceiling but I want
to see it more as in like when you go to
an airport in Las Vegas say Las Vegas
Aces gear see the different teams in
those areas I mean there's a lot of
people that we're not in season we're
off season more than we're in season but
it doesn't mean people don't go to Vegas
it doesn't mean people don't go to
Phoenix and everywhere else in between I
think we need to see more of the wnbj
teams and women's sports teams and
airports in different situations for
people to support even though we might
not be in season or even though we might
not be there I think that's the perfect
thing to do let them buy that Jersey let
them buy that t-shirt like that's how we
push it yeah if you can see her you can
be hers but I always say yeah so just
visibility is about putting it in your
face makes it meaningful like in a very
real real way yes okay I do want to end
on this because John Moran is a huge
friend of the show he is one of my
closest friends he's been on here like
six times literally he has done the show
six times
um and I know that you all are also very
close to such an advocate for women he
has your back like no other that is one
thing about drama rant he's gonna spin
the block for you what do you think
really bonds you and jaw oh man I feel
like I remember watching jahoop uh I
think probably in Sumter as a young kid
just like incredible Talent just who he
is and I think that is so pure and now
watching him now I'm like that is not
the same kid I was watching like just
watching him grow up it's been
incredible to watch and he's he's just
there he's just scratching the surface
and I think the thing that ties us
together is one of her work and us we
never change like we are who we are
um we gonna be who we are we're gonna be
that country people from South Carolina
we don't really care what people say
because that's who we are and we live it
and to share this moment with his dad
and his parents and my parents when they
came to playoffs it was just a true
moment and that's the little bro for
sure I always got his back 100 and just
to watch from flourishing in the NBA has
been a pleasure to watch especially
watching him when he was just a young
kid with a little twist baby with the
little
frogs
like the dude starting five
but now he's like oh he's like a grown
man and it's just incredible to watch
him yes no I love hearing that and there
really are I think a lot of parallels
yeah and both of you your energy on
South Carolina your bond with your
parents so it's really beautiful
um last thing though you don't like
loving basketball you got to tell me why
oh loving basketball is a trash movie
because like what don't nobody do none
of that girl what do not play me for my
heart I got time for that like why do
people go and do what you did no
absolutely not I cannot stand loving
basketball it's one of the worst movies
I've ever seen and I'm not just saying
it people say it's not in my generation
and I don't understand it but no I can't
get down with loving basketball and it's
a lot of people on set that's looking at
me crazy but um loving basketball is not
giving what it needs to give I'm so
sorry I cannot why I cannot stand that
movie I cannot stand that movie I will
say this I like loving basketball but no
I recognize the problematic aspects of
Love and Basketball no you still
[Music]
okay then favorite basketball movie
every basketball movie I like Coach
Carter that's a good picture
Okay so everybody watch coach fighter if
you haven't hey we got some
disagreements
loving basketball is trash it is but
it's a lot of monikas out there looking
for their Quincy so I hope y'all find
them
but hey do not judge yourself you endure
ladies okay he should have had it
together
yes no but I feel y'all though by the
way you know we got way back we was
together with the Nick so me and her we
right here okay no I love it you are so
much fun thank you so much for having us
inviting us to your Camp all the things
I will be rooting for you and I hope
y'all go back to that girl thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]